الشتاء قادم من لا يعرف هذه الجمله من
المسلسل الشهير صراع العروش بالتاكيد
سيكون سمعها من المسؤولين الاوروبيين حول
ازمه الطاقه والغاز في الشتاء لكن الكارثه
الموعوده قبل تاتي في النهايه على الاقل
في المانيا في الواقع شبح والطاقه لا يزال
يخيم على اوروبا على رغم الاعلان
استعدادها لمواجهتها هذا الشتاء لكن
الارقام تظهر لنا مخزونها من الغاز الشبه
ممتلئ وان الامور تحت السيطره ما لم يجرح
الشتاء نحو بروده غير اعتياديه الواضح ان
الازمه اظهرت وعي الناس في اوروبا لضروره
التكيف ربما الابتعاد قليلا عن منطقه
الراحه المطلقه المزيد مع ايهم قاسم
المانيا
[موسيقى]
تنفس الالمان السعداء بعد نشر بياناتي
وكاله الطاقه الفيدراليه في المانيا
لتصيله الى نسبه 99 بالمئه وفقا لاحدث
البيانات
[موسيقى]
فرحه الالماني لم تكتمل بعد تحضيرات رئيس
الوكاله الاتحاديه الالمانيه للشبكات
كلاوس مولر من احتمال نفذ المخزون بسرعه
اذا جاء الطقس في الشتاء شديد البروده دعى
الالمان للتوفير في الاستهلاك واستخدام
وسائله بديله
[موسيقى]
الغاز الحاليه تكفي لمعاصره عمل اكبر
اقتصاد في اوروبا فقط لتسعه او عشره
اسابيع بشرط ان يكون الشتاء متوسطه
البروده كما كان الحال في العام الماضي
اوروبا استعدت ايضا الى حد مالي مواجهه
هذا الشتاء مع خزانات الغاز شبه ممتلئه
وصلت نسبتها نهايه اكتوبر الى 95 بالمئه
لكن كيف تغلبت اوروبا على ازمه الطاقه هذا
العام استطعت اوروبا الوصول لهذه
المستويات من خلال دعم واردات الغاز
الطبيعي
الاوروبيين بالازمه وفي ظل طقسا معتدل
خلال اكتوبر وهو الى
نوفمبردات الطاقه هذا الشتاء واجلها بشتاء
العام المقبل برنامج صباح العربي ايهم
القاسم
[موسيقى]
ومن ازمه الطاقه في اوروبا الى حلول ازمه
المنى وهو موضوعنا من شرم الشيخ اليوم قبل
ان ننتقل الى مراسل الى هناك المزيد مع
الاسره
وبنود مهمه على طاوله القاده والمسؤولين
والناشطين في قمه المناخ كوب 27 في شرم
الشيخ البند الابرز الخسائر والاضرار بكل
بساطه ان البلدان الاكثر تضررا من
الاحتباس الحراري تطلب مساعده ماليه
للتعامل مع عواقب الفيضانات والجفاف
وغيرها من اثار تغير المناخ هذه التغطيه
تكون لخسائر اقتصاديه مثل المنازل
والاراضي والمزارع والشركات وخسائر غير
اقتصاديه كموت الناس او خساره المواقع
الثقافيه او فقدان التنوع البيولوجي من
الموضوعات الاساسيه ايضا التي تناقشها
القمه ان يكون التنفيذ هو الهدف الاساسي
اي حان الوقت لتطبيق بنود اتفاق باريس
للمناخ والتعهدات التي جرى التوافق عليها
سابقا كذلك سيركز المجتمعون على تنحيه
الخلافات السياسيه جانبا
وسط تصاعد حده التوترات بين الولايات
المتحده والصين والتصعيد في حرب اوكرانيا
ايضا مناقشه حق الدول الناميه في
الاستمرار في استخدام الوقود الاحفوري
اثناء سعيهم للنمو باعتباره معركه بين
الاهداف المناخيه للدول المتقدمه وحاجه
الدول الناميه للتقدم
[موسيقى]
على كل المزيد ينضم الينا بشرم الشيخ
مراسل صباح العربيه احمد عثمان احمد يسعد
صباحك اهلا بك من مصر الحبيبه احمد عندما
نتحدث اليوم عن المناخ نتحدث عن زياده
انبعاثات كربونيه اتحدث عن ازمه طاقه قبل
حلول فصل الشتاء ولا تحدث عن اتساع فجوه
التمويل مصر اليوم تعد بتحويل كل الوعود
في القمم السابقه حول المناخ الى تنفيذ
باجراءات ملموسه ما الذي ينتظره العالم من
قمه شرم الشيخ 27
لعب صباح الخير لكي ولي الساده المشاهدين
بالفعل كما ذكرت في المقدمه هناك الانظار
تتجه اليوم الى شرم الشيخ خلال اليومين
المقبلين وصولا الى يوم 18 نهايه هذا
المؤتمر والتوصيات التي ستخرج به ربما
الحضور القوي من قبل الرؤساء والزعماء الى
شرم الشيخ والذي يعني بدا بالفعل والمتوقع
ان يطردته اليوم من قاده من اوروبا واسيا
وافريقيا والعالم العربي يؤكد على ما تمت
على ما طرحته سهام من اهميه هذا المؤتمر
والربما ما تم احرازه من خلال ادراج بعض
النقاط المهمه اول جلاليه من خلال جدول
الاعمال وربما الرئيسيه في ما يتعلق بنقطه
التمويل هذه النقطه والتي كانت تتعلق به
ضروره ان يكون هناك تمويل وصلت يعني
تقيماته الى مئه مليون دولار سنويا ان
يكون على جدول الاعمال والتجاوز كل
الحساسيات والخلافات من كونه عليه تعويضات
امويل كل هذه الامور التي كانت صغيره
وعائقه همم تم تجوزها وهناك ربما نضرب من
التفاؤل فيما يتعلق بامكانيه الانتقال من
حيز العناوين العريضه التي تاتي في
المؤتمرات الى الوصول الى حيز التنفيذ
الفعلي على الارض كل هذه النقاط سيتم
استعراضها خلال الايام اليوم وغدا سيكون
هناك كلمات همم القاده يوم الرئيس يصل الى
شرم الشيخ يوم الجمعه في زياره تستغرق ست
ساعات سيلقي كلماته وايضا سيكون هناك خلال
هذه الايام ربما العديد من المشاورات
واللقاءات الثنائيه التي تجمع القاده او
بعض ايضا مع المختصين والمحللين لانتقال
فعليا سيكون هناك ايضا استعراض للكثير من
ما تم طرحه على ارض الواقع خلال الفتره
الماضيه هناك جناح لي المملكه العربيه
السعوديه سيكون هناك استعراض لما تم
تحقيقه منذ الاعلان عن مبادره الشرق
الاوسط الكبير والشرق والس الخضراء اا في
نهايه العام الماضي سيتم طرح ايضا ما تم
تحقيقه في السعوديه فيما يتعلق بيئه
الانتقال الى عالم اكثر خضره واقل اضرار
بيئيه كل هذه الامور في شرم الشيخ ستكون
شاهده عليها خلال الايام المقبله في ظل
ربما نوع نبرا من التفاؤل هناك ايضا يعني
استمرار لبعض الخلافات كان هناك احباط حول
الاجماع بان فكره الوصول الى واحد في
المئه ونصف انبعاثات حراريه يعني يبقى شبه
مستحيل ولكن هناك ايضا جهود للتواصل
لعمليات اخرى تقلل من عمليات الاضرار
المناخيه وتاثيراتها السلبيه خصوصا على
الدول الناميه وتحديدا القاره الافريقيه
اليوم بخطه انقاذ بصحيح العباره يا احمد
هل من تفاصيل حول خطه المصريه لانقاذه هنا
نعم يعني هذه الخطه ربما تبدو ملامحها
مبدئيا فيما يتعلق بتحقيق فكره الانتقال
الى عمليه التمويل الى حيز الفعل وليس حيز
الشعارات هذه هي النقطه التي كانت عالقه
هذه النقطه التي كانت تنادي بها الكثير من
الدول الناميه خلال السنوات الاعوام
الماضيه كان هناك ربما رؤيه مشتركه من هذه
الدول بان هذا العنوان البراق يبقى مجرد
نقطه قائده للتفاوض ما بين الدول الغنيه
ما بين دول الاقتصاد
الاقتصاديات الكبيره او الصناعات الصناعات
المهمه تحديدا في الغرب وتحقيقه فعليا من
خلال الانتقال الى مساعدات فعليه الى هذه
الدول كيف سيت- ستكون هذه المساعدات الى
الدول الناميه لتجاوز فيما تجاوز
تعثيراتها في ما يتعلق بالاضرار البيئيه
هذه النقاط ربما يبقى التفاصيل ولكن في حد
ذاته ان يكون هناك على جدول الاعمال اتفاق
مبداي او اتفاق من حيث المبدا على مبدا
ليس التعويضات لانها كلمه التعويضات ربما
تثير حساسيات ولكن مبدا التمويل الفعلي من
الدول الغنيه عبر الامم المتحده الى الدول
الفقيره او الدول الناميه لتجاوز الاضرار
البيئيه هذا العنوان في حد ذاته كان مبهجا
للكثيرين وكان محل فرحه حيث انه تم
الانتقال اخيرا كانت هذه النقطه ربما يتم
تجاوزها يتم تاجيلها ولكن منذ انطلاق قمه
باريس ولكن الان يبدو الوضع مختلفا ويعكس
نبرا من التفاؤل بانه ربما الامور الاخرى
الفنيه قد تحل تدريجيا مع وجود هذا البلد
او تحقيق هذا البنك
تعزيز الدولي لمواجهه التغير المناخ شكرا
جزيلا من شرم الشيخ
[موسيقى]